[Music]
lindy
this is not a cure the only way we're
going to make progress
is cutting edge avant-garde treatment
i've got this condition it makes me snap
like tourette's just tiny bit more
[Music]
intense i've upped the voltage
but there's only so much that the human
body can take
[Music]
hello this is detective vickers sounds
like your guy was involved in some
pretty sketchy business
i'm gonna find you did this
if you go down that path you are never
ever going to get better
deal with her you spent years being
forced to repress your anger
but now you have seen how powerful you
can be when you embrace your
age oh seriously you're gonna make me go
through the whole
face stomping bone breaking making a
mess routine
okay fine
you're gonna get somebody killed i'm
trying to help you uh-huh
how's that going for you
what is it about gross old men always
underestimating women
are you really that stupid you know what
i think i am
exactly that stupid
you